Hello, everybody. Welcome to a new episode of
the Decent. I'm your host as always Ricardo Loops
. And today I'm joined by Doctor Stephanie. Her
, she is a researcher, broadcaster and author focused
on technology, politics and history. And today we're
going to talk about her book Technology is Not Neutral
, a short guide to technology ethics. So doctor
her, welcome to the show. It's a pleasure
to everyone. Thank you so much for having me
or Gala. Great. So um uh tech uh
technology ethics, I guess that uh people who think
about is who look at these would think that OK
, it's just another uh philosophy thing. Why should
we care about that? It's just some about some
abstract questions. But I mean, what is it
really about? And what kinds of uh more practical
questions, let's say, does it deal with?
I love, I love your idea of like one
more philosophy is if we're being bombarded by philosophies and
all the time, and there's just philosophers walking around
selling their wares in the street, which I guess
is maybe true, we would just call them marketing
people now. Uh No. So I think,
look, I think technology and the way that humans
have a relationship with technology has existed probably since we
, you know, developed depos, thumbs and started
making tools. Um, you know, so we
would have picked up bones or stones or twigs and
started fashioning them creating fire. And probably from that
moment you started having human beings disagreeing about, you
know, when is it acceptable to make a fire
? What are the rules around fire? Is fire
for cooking and keeping us warm and keeping predators away
or is it ok to like torch our enemy camps
village? Um, or use it, you know
, launch it into an arrow and shoot it at
people. So I just feel like in some ways
it's like nothing new under the sun, as Shakespeare
said, it's, it's always been there. So
I don't feel like this is like a new idea
, um that people are hawking. I think it's
, it's one of the oldest things because it's so
fundamental to us. Beings have been making technology,
you know, for a really long time. And
we've also been philosophizing for a really long time because
if we think about philosophy, kind of the way
it's taught today, it's very abstract. We think
about it in universities, uh you know, philosophy
departments writing about topics that most of us probably are
never going to read a book about, uh or
an article or really care, which is a shame
because we're actually doing philosophy all the time. We're
doing it every day. So if you're interested in
, in power and in politics that welcome to philosophy
, you're doing political philosophy. If you're interested in
like good and bad, right and wrong, um
where do we draw the line on certain things?
Welcome to philosophy. You're doing ethics. If you
have really strong views on aesthetics, which could be
anything from, you know, design in your house
to like the sustainability or labor relations that go into
the materials that you buy, any product that you
buy or service that you buy or even things like
user design and user experience. Welcome to philosophy,
you are doing aesthetics, right, and so on
and so forth. So we're doing it all the
time, but I think we weren't certainly in the
Anglo Saxon world, we're not really taught it in
the way that often you are in the continent much
more explicitly. So I think that was like the
first bridge I wanted to build with people that I
work with both in my client work. But also
in my writing was to kind of get everybody confident
with the fact that actually you've already been doing this
your whole life. So now that we give you
the terms, you have like a name for what
you're doing. And I can take you through examples
of how you've been doing it, that's a bit
empowering and confidence building. So now you can start
doing it deliberately because that is uh that is a
shift. I think there's something really cool about how
philosophy exists as a tool set. It's very practical
. It's very pragmatic. So if you're facing,
oh, I don't know, a problem or an
opportunity you're trying to evaluate to do something or not
to do something or just what you think about something
. Like, what's your point of view on it
? Sometimes, particularly today, life is very complicated
. It can be nice to have a tool set
that helps you to think through things so that you
can do it with a bit of rigor and then
you can talk about it. It gives you like
a shared menu if you will a shared script for
talking about it with other people. And it's really
nice if you're a problem solver by a profession,
which doesn't necessarily mean you have to be a technologist
or an engineer. You might be a problem solver
as a lawyer, as a regulator. Um You
might be, or even as like a CEO and
you're having to figure out, you know, do
we go this way or that way? What,
what problem I'm trying to solve here. It can
be really nice because it's like a due diligence exercise
that allows you, you can go through it and
when you're done, you're like, OK, I've
done this, I've done this, I've done this
, I've done this and that's really helpful. So
I think that's the thing that I find really exciting
about technology ethics is it's really practical. Like when
I go in and teach this to people afterwards,
they're like, we're doing our, the way our
team functions is different now or the way that we
tackle opportunity and risk assessment is different now and by
different, I'm hoping they mean better. Right.
So it doesn't have to necessarily be right now.
A I Ethics is very buzzy and has been for
a couple of years. But like, I don't
limit my analysis to A II I go as broad
as you can in terms of all technology because A
I is just, it's an exciting technology and it
is definitely the technology of the day in terms of
the media and marketing cycle. But there's so much
more, there's so much more we can do with
philosophy in terms of the human tech relationship. So
I think it's really fun. I wouldn't, I
wouldn't have spent my time on it if I found
it boring or not useful. Um On the contrary
, once I started really working with this, I
was like, this is powerful and it's helpful and
that is great because if you are trying to tackle
particularly complicated problems, you need every tool that you
have. Uh And I mean, the main question
you tackle in the book is, is technology neutral
. And uh of course, just by looking at
the title, your position is obvious, but e
even before we get into your position and go through
some examples that really are illustrative of the fact that
technology might not be neutral. Give us perhaps some
examples of arguments from the other side. People who
argue that technology is indeed neutral, that you find
perhaps the most compelling. Yeah. So I actually
used to think technology was neutral. It was,
it was in the writing of the book that I
had to change my mind and I'll give a few
examples of why I used to think this. Um
First of all, I came from a business perspective
where and I should declare my nationality interest. So
I'm American by birth. And then I've had my
career in the United Kingdom. So this is very
much an Anglo Saxon uh free market capitalism, hardcore
perspective because I appreciate that's not the case everywhere.
Uh For your global audience of this interview, that
perspective uh is very anti regulation. Regulation is always
being portrayed as like hindering innovation. It's going to
stop innovation and innovation is really key particularly in the
US, you know, to American superpower, competitiveness
. So anything that would hinder that instantly becomes political
, it doesn't matter if you're a Republican or Democrat
, everybody's like, oh, nobody wants to,
everything that hinders that is the bloody communists. Exactly
. Like take your pick. Are we scared of
like the former Soviet Union in the eighties? It
was Japan now. It's China, right? So
like nobody wants to hinder innovation with pesky regulation.
Uh so you have, you have that, that
right there shows you like, it's not at the
end of the, the innovation cycle. If you
will, you decide, you build something and you
decide if you're going to regulate it or not,
that is inherently not neutral. But the way it
was being portrayed to argue against regulation, you would
be like, whoa, whoa, whoa um you
know, classic example in the United States is guns
don't kill people, people kill people. And that
argument has been if you will weaponized uh very successfully
in the United States to stop us from doing any
real meaningful gun control. Not just because we have
the second amendment which gives Americans the right to bear
arms, but when that law was crafted, we
didn't have some of the weapons that we have today
that you can buy at your local Walmart. Um
often without an ID background check, it's actually quite
staggering. And so the founding fathers were not imagining
taking guns and walking into a school and shooting up
an entire school, which unfortunately is a very common
occurrence now, um, tragically, all too common
. And so I started looking at being like,
well on the one hand, it is true guns
do not on their own, kill someone because they
can't like self pull the trigger, they can't self
shoot if you will. Although people I'm sure are
now working on building guns that do exactly that A
I powered weaponry but even then there's a human that's
, that's ultimately coding that and controlling it. So
it's still, there's always a human that takes the
gun and makes the decision to pull a trigger.
But I also was like, yeah, but the
muskets that were there in the 18th century are really
different from like an A K 15 assault rifle.
You can kill a lot more people with the latter
than with the former. So like a gun is
not just a gun, like even within like the
gun analogy, the amount of harm I can do
with a musket versus like a pistol versus like the
kind of weaponry that frankly, you should only ever
be seeing held by the military in like a theater
of war and is unfortunately on the street or in
people's homes, um is, is like inherently not
neutral. There were design choices that went into the
making of the gun, the way that the bullets
are done. Um There's like cop killer bullets that
can pierce um body armor, right? So like
the people who designed that knew that and the people
who are choosing to sell it know it. So
like they're not neutral either because you could decide to
be like, we're not selling guns here and there
indeed was a sporting store in the U SI think
it was Dick's sporting good sporting goods, which decided
not to. And then it got this massive blowback
and it became a national issue precisely because they were
exercising their right not to sell. Right. But
that's not neutral because now you're like removing my,
my right. Damn it to have guns. Um
, so this isn't like a, I don't want
to make a sort of pro or anti gun statement
. I have my own view on that obviously,
of course, as a citizen, I'm sure it's
probably obvious from here. But what I mean is
even with something that's like such a little easy example
, like guns, easy. And compared in comparison
to A I because it's just a physical, you
know, tool, even that you start to realize
like it is not neutral to decide to design bullets
that can pierce wound right. There's like no other
reason that you would do that. There's no other
purpose of particularly a good benign purpose that you could
use that for. So when you start thinking about
it in that way, you can actually start looking
at pretty much, I'm just looking around my my
house right now, like almost any object, you're
like, shit. Somebody has designed every aspect of
it from the, the raw materials that were pulled
out of the ground to like the environmental impact of
that, to how much the workers all got paid
all along the supply chain, all of it.
Um Whether or not it's designed for the majority of
the population, which is right handed or like,
do we take left handed people into account What about
if you're color blind? What if you have like
dyslexia, like every single design consideration is not neutral
. And that's just, that's just, again,
that's for like analog world, physical objects. Now
you take that to the next level and you start
getting into code, it's the same principle, but
it's also like turbocharged because A I, one of
the things that's fascinating about what the world we're living
in now is that because we have more data than
ever before and computer processing power than ever before.
We can do things faster and at a greater scale
than at any time in human history. Whether or
not that will hold by the way is very contentious
. We don't know if we've reached the limits of
computer processing power. For instance, we definitely haven't
reached the limits of data. So that starts getting
really messy. You also look at like who is
doing the designing, be it for code or a
physical object and those groups are not representative of the
whole of our populations, which is why it can
sound like diversity and equality and inclusion. We call
it de I here. I'm not sure what it
is in, in um Portuguese, but you probably
have a similar concept for it. Yeah, the
initials are pretty much the same, the same.
Ok, cool. So de I can in many
ways just seem like another version of being politically correct
writer in the United States. A woke and it
seems like a bad thing. I don't look at
it as a bad thing in terms of the political
sense. I look at it from a design perspective
of being like I want, if I'm selling something
, you know, bring out the capitalism. If
I'm selling a service or a tool or a product
, I want it to work for the vast majority
, it ideally for everybody. So I have a
challenge there because I need it to scale. But
I also need to be able to personalize and customize
, depending on your individual needs or the needs of
your company or the needs of the country that you're
based in. Right? Because you might have different
laws there. Um How do I, how do
I focus on that? And that kind of stuff
really fascinates me because I don't understand why it gets
lampooned so much in certain certain branches of the press
and indeed investment communities as being politicized because I'm like
, that's just truly, that's just good business.
But like that, you know, that's just my
, that's just my view, but I would assume
as a good hearted capitalist that you would want to
design products that the, you know, the majority
of people can buy because that's, you know,
catching more money. So it's very strange. Um
So I guess that's what I mean when I say
like technology ethics is so much bigger than just like
, is something good or bad. Like that's a
really binary way of looking at it. It's very
complex and rich. It's like a tapestry, you
start pulling on one thread and then you pull on
another and another and you, you know, you
come out with this whole complex analysis that you can
use if you wish to make things better. Yeah
, I mean, at a certain point there,
you mentioned regulation and regulation across different countries. And
perhaps later in the interview when we talk about specific
kinds of technologies, we can come back to this
because uh recently with the release of threads, it's
interesting because here in the European Union, it's not
available yet and it has to do with data privacy
, online privacy, data collection, data, the
ownership and all of that. So uh we can
come back to this uh later. But uh I
mean, uh at a certain point you mentioned there
or alluded to one of the points you make in
the book because at a certain point you talk about
or explore the idea of what is a tool and
the di the difference, for example, between tools
that are found and tools that are created. So
uh uh tell us a little bit about that because
I think it's very helpful in terms of trying to
reframe the way we think about these questions. Yeah
. So for me, this was um I wrote
a lot of the book during the pandemic during lockdown
. Uh And I would, you know, I
go for my sort of hour long walk sometimes longer
than an hour who the British police will find out
now that I was walking for an hour and a
half. Um, I would do these really long
laps around my local park and, you know,
there was such a weird time. Right. It
was such a strange time for all of us and
I started to really go into some fairly abstract directions
of thinking. And so one of the things was
like, let's think of the most neutral tool possible
and then the most like non neutral tool. So
my examples because, you know, I wanted to
like draw the, the map if you will or
draw matrix, you know, so what's what's like
the most neutral and the the most completely value laden
um thing. So the, the hardcore one for
me was the atomic bomb, which was, there's
only one reason that you would build an atomic bomb
and only one reason you're really going to use it
, which is to harm because there's, there's no
like there's no way of getting around that harm.
It will, you know, the radiation damage to
any human that comes within the blast radius and also
just like other parts of nature for sure. Um
is just non negotiable, it's going to happen in
physics. So there's that, but there's also like
the only two times that human beings have used,
it was in the theater of war Right. So
, it was like, it was designed in a
war to be used in a war and we have
lived under the shadow of threat of nuclear war ever
since. And I grew up in the Cold War
in the US. So, for me as a
child, this was like the scariest thing that could
ever happen to human beings as a nuke, like
a rogue nuke situation or nukes getting out of control
and just decimating entire countries. And very, unfortunately
recently we've been living more or less through that kind
of fear and we're still living through that. Yeah
, I mean, that's the thing is like,
everybody freaks out about A I, and I'm like
, there's all these nukes, you know, it's
like thousands and thousands of them and like, lots
of countries have them that maybe shouldn't and it's too
late now. Like, we can't put that genie
back in the bottle. So that was like,
that was, that was over here in my most
extreme example of a technology that, like, you
just wouldn't use a nuke for something good. Maybe
you would have like, aliens were coming or an
asteroid that was attacking earth and the only way we
could stop it would be if we, like,
launched a nuke out in space to, you know
, blow up the asteroid. This is how I
talk with little kids about tech ethics and they're like
, they get it. They're like, yeah,
you nuke against the asteroid. Maybe not the alien
though. But, uh, we would want to
talk with them first. Perhaps so. Yeah.
Yeah. Perhaps. Let's not just assume immediately that
they would come here to work and we would be
preemptively killing another life farmer. I mean, come
on, let's just give them a chance. Exactly
. That's, that's my view as well in case
they're listening. Uh, but then the other extreme
I was like, well, what's the other,
other extreme? And I got really into looking at
nature when I was on my walks. And of
course, this led to animals who use tools because
what humans are not the only species that make tools
, which is so cool, you can really go
down a rabbit hole with this. Um And I
did, I went down that rabbit hole so that
you don't have to and looked at all of the
different ways that animals fashion tools. And of course
, this starts to become if you're interested in the
history of what differentiates human beings from our other ape
chimpanzee brethren. One of the big questions was human
beings make tools. That's like a defining characteristic of
what it means to be human, which is kind
of trippy if you think about. Well, so
the crows. So like, why is, why
is that about making us human? But it just
is. And so that was one of the things
when Jane Goodall was um doing her amazing research about
chimpanzees and she wrote to her then phd supervisor to
describe what she was observing and he wrote back saying
either we have to redefine what a tool is or
we have to redefine what man is. And I
was like, oh, there's something in this.
And so it was like, well, what are
those animals doing? And what were we doing?
So, they were doing something along the lines of
what I call a found tool. So they would
find an object in nature, a stone, um
, a branch and they would fashion it in some
way to make a weapon. Usually it's used to
hunt for food, um, rather than harm others
, trapping food, et cetera, but it showed
like advanced cognitive abilities. So I was like,
ok, they're taking something that, that exists already
and they're fashioning it in some way and they're coming
up with really interesting uses for it. And there's
a number of species that do it, of which
we are one. So let's call that like the
most even fire potentially could be viewed as neutral in
the sense that it exists in nature. Like you
can just look over in Canada right now where you're
just getting these spontaneous wildfires because of the heat or
when lightning strikes the earth, it can spark fires
so that can exist in. So we didn't like
invent fire. Nature invented fire. We just figured
out how to harness it and then deliberately create conditions
in which fire appears So I took that thinking and
went back to the atomic bomb thinking and was like
, OK, what do we mean by the atomic
bomb? Because there's a whole process, you don't
just start with an atomic bomb, they're incredibly difficult
to build. Thank God uh given the harm that
they can do. So I started reading honestly,
it's like bringing back all these weird pandemic memories.
But I spent like months, months and months reading
about the journey to make that bomb and the scientists
who started out working on it were not doing it
to make a weapon, which I think is important
because what you want to do is you want to
identify where, where from like the first discovery to
the first detonation over Hiroshima and the Nagasaki, where
in that line do you cross, do you cross
a line and it stops being neutral? So I
was like, OK, the scientists who are just
looking to understand what happens when you bombard uranium,
that's just like pure science and the, the information
of that the fact of that exists in nature or
whether or not we ever discovered it as humans,
it would exist because again, it's, it's,
it's physics. So when does it start to become
a weapon? And I identified in the book that
it becomes a weapon in the mind of a brilliant
Hungarian scientist, Leo Solar as he was walking down
the street here in London, he attended a lecture
, I think in 1938 and he suddenly had this
idea of how to do it. And because he
was friends with everyone, he's an amazing man.
His book, Genius In The Shadows. It's a
book about his life is really worth reading to discover
like the networking of science and how an idea goes
from idea to weapon or hopefully the idea to vaccine
or idea to, you know, wonderful cure that
will save us all from climate change. So he
goes and talks to Einstein about it and because both
of them were Central European and Jewish, which I
think is also very important, they recognize the threat
of Hitler far earlier than their American counterparts did.
And they were like a, you could do this
with the scientific information that we now have about how
to split the atom, you could do this and
you could weaponize it and we think that Hitler will
so we'd better have a plan in place. And
because Einstein was able due to his incredible status as
a Nobel Prize winner to get an audience with the
then US President Franklin Delano Roosevelt, they explained this
to him, laid it out and then FDR green
lit the deal if you will to create what became
the Manhattan project, which ended up involving over 1000
scientists and you know, massive budget and became a
military project and scientists from all over the world worked
on it. So you're like, so was it
FDR that did it because he, he gave like
the political nouse if you will and power and approval
and money. Was it Einstein who like formed the
bridge? Because Leo Solar could have had the idea
. We all have great ideas, but like that
doesn't necessarily lead to them being executed. So there's
like a chain. It was like solar. Einstein
FDRFDR then tasked Ben our Bush who is like head
of all of America's totally cool World War Two science
stuff. Another fascinating person to read about Robert Oppenheimer
. Now subject of a major movie uh who led
, you know, who like literally run the man
project. All of it was absolutely fascinating for me
to like I had to build out the map of
who was working on it. You know, you
could ultimately be like, no, all of these
things could have happened and it actually comes down to
the pilots who flew the plane and dropped the two
bombs because they were the last kind of line of
defense who could have, I don't know, made
an ethical protest and done what many people wanted by
that point, which was a demonstration of the bomb
but not on a human population. You could have
dropped it out in the ocean to let people see
what it was capable of doing. And hopefully,
then that would have made Japan surrender. That was
like an actual idea that was being put forward.
But by that point the new president, Harry Truman
was like, no, we have to do this
because he was given statistics saying if we don't drop
this bomb and the fighting continues for another 18 months
, which were the predictions, however many people will
die and it was in the millions. So he
was weighing up his ethical calculus, right. And
it's easy for all of us to judge these things
now knowing what we know now. But back then
they didn't know and they had to make a call
and they'd already been fighting war for a really long
time. And, you know, we can argue
about that and people do argue about that until the
cows come home. So for me, I didn't
want to argue about it. I wanted to sort
of forensically map it because I can see it happening
again. Uh I can see it happening in all
sorts of different things. And like, I don't
mean in the sense of it's leading to death.
I mean, I, I can see it happening
again in that we are in this incredible moment of
flourishing scientifically and technologically. This is an, this
is an amazing time. Like people will write about
this. I think centuries later from now that this
was like a real turning point moment in human science
and technology evolution. And so what I'm hoping to
do many people are working on this, I'm just
like one tiny little person. But what I'm hoping
to do um as a historian in training is like
, write the history of the future, which is
like, ok, so if, if we've got
a, I now, what can we learn from
the atomic bomb exercise that we just went through?
You? And I here today to understand who's working
, for instance, on A I, although it
can also be genetic engineering, it could be any
technology, put it in the whole point is that
it should work for anything who's working on it.
What are the ethical decisions that are in play?
Who has the power to actually get things done or
more importantly to stop something, right? All of
that stuff and also who doesn't have the power,
who's just on the receiving end of this? Because
like, you know, the atomic crisis, if
you will, that resulted from 1945 I think helped
a lot of people to understand that this is something
that affects all of humanity, but not all of
humanity was involved in the design and deployment considerations.
And even with nuclear arms control, even today,
certain countries have a greater voice in that than others
. And that matters because you hear with people talking
about A I governance and they're like, we should
have an international Atomic Energy Agency like exists today in
Vienna to look at nuclear technology. We should have
something like that for A I. And it's like
, well, OK, let's just check that,
that interesting idea. Let's examine that is the IAE
A actually a good example, a template a model
for us to use to govern A I. And
like we need to interview the people who are working
on it and also their critics and come up with
that view, I've seen some people really dismiss it
. You also saw a bunch of people saying we
should have a CERN for A I research. So
cern being the particle physics laboratory that's based on the
French Swiss border as physicists again from around the world
. And it's public, public science, if you
will public interest science, so you would want to
talk with CERN and be like, OK, like
we have an example, we run the CERN experiment
now for, you know, 5060 years. Do
you think that's actually relevant and appropriate if it isn't
, could we do better with an A I research
lab? What would that look like to make it
fair equitable? Um representative more democratic. Uh how
do we factor in things like climate and biodiversity,
which we didn't necessarily in the early atomic discussions but
actually really matter that sort of thing. So I
think there's a lot we can learn from the history
of this found technology if it's just something that's out
there versus something that you very deliberately set out to
make like an atomic bomb and most of us when
we're making technology or using it or investing in it
uh or buying it are not ever going to have
to face the extremes of an atomic weapon, but
we'll probably be somewhere closer from, we just found
something and we, we like fashioned it or we're
deliberately creating something that's probably more middle of the road
between those two. So that's a really long example
. But I think it's quite important because you can't
really rush through talking about nuclear technology. Um,
and it matters because now we're having this big conversation
globally about how to regulate A I and thing that
people keep coming back to again and again and again
is the nuclear war threat. They also cite the
pandemic threat given that we've all just lived through that
. I think we all had a very uh upfront
close and personal stress test of pandemic governance and health
governance and bio laboratory governance, right? Like was
this a virus that was manufactured in the lab?
Was it something that came from nature? Like this
is something that's still being discussed? Scientists are still
evolving their views on that and even if it is
something that was found in nature, it still raises
the issue of these labs, right? And like
how the ethics, the ethics of bioengineering that all
comes from World War Two, all of that thinking
medical ethics, all of it really got an update
from World War Two. So if you want to
think about the technologies of the future, knowing your
second World War Science and technology studies, history from
the second World War onwards I think is essential,
right? You know, you have, you can't
, you can't be talking about A I to today
in the abstract, you have to know we've already
seen scientists taking ethical stances and doctors taking ethical stances
. Um, some people have said that A I
should be regulated more like the food and drug agency
in the United States. Like you can't just,
you can't just roll out a drug on the American
population. It has to go through extremely rigorous testing
, right? And God forbid when we're talking about
global pharmaceutical manufacturing or global research um or research on
the human body or embryos and stem cell tissue,
right? Like there's entire governance structures set up for
this that come from weirdly a World War Two starting
framework because that's when we saw not just the potentially
positive but also controversial narrative around atomic weapons, but
also a lot of the Nazi medical experiments and bioresearch
experiments, which were absolutely horrific, right? So
all of that thinking is there. So if you
don't know that thinking you're doing the classic thing that
tech people do, which is like, oh what
if we invented this thing? And you're like,
you've invented something that's literally already existed and that people
have been working on for decades, like do your
literature review before you start talking, right? So
classic. So classic, I mean, let me
just ask you one question about all of what you
what you've just said. So, um, you've
talked mostly about nuclear weapons and you also have the
discovery of nuclear fusion, for example. And uh
I, I was wondering if you think that perhaps
certain scientific discoveries themselves might not be neutral because I
, I mean, we could, we could just
say, uh and I'm not pointing fingers at anyone
that studies or studied nuclear fission. I mean,
it's uh as far as I, as I,
as I'm concerned, it's perfectly fine to understand how
atoms work and all of that. And the same
for how genes work, for example. But at
the same time, isn't it the case that uh
first of all people, uh people who are making
the scientific discoveries themselves are people and they have their
own motivations and their work is u usually uh uh
paid for by governments or private institutions. And that's
also not random or usually not arbitrary. I mean
, if they pay for something, they have particular
goals in mind, they want certain developments instead of
others, they want c to work. Why there
certain knowledge instead of some other knowledge? So could
it also, could you think or say that certain
scientific discoveries are themselves not neutral even though they are
just uh just uh uh at first sight producing useful
knowledge or? Well, I think it's probably important
to differentiate between the discovery and what leads to it
. So, back in the day when I thought
that technology was neutral before I wrote a book of
the change if I was coming from the, the
sort of technology um digital perspective. And I was
like, this is math, this is mathematics and
you hear that a lot um like Gary Kasparov,
the chess grandmaster who wrote a book on A I
called Deep Thinking was like on Twitter a few years
ago. And I cited him in the book saying
ethical A I is like ethical, electricity, like
electricity is just electricity. Like he was kind of
like, what is this uh this argument? And
I, I understand what he means and you see
it a lot. I follow Twitter obsessively and I'm
constantly watching people argue about code is neutral. Math
is neutral and all these people are trying to talk
about values, but math has no values. It's
like the universal language. And I understand that just
like a phenomenon that exists in chemistry or a phenomenon
that exists in physics. Again, putting the atom
has like doesn't care what my politics are or who
writes my paycheck, right? Like it just,
it just exists, it's knowledge. So I think
that part is, is neutral, something that just
exists, is neutral in the natural physical world.
That doesn't mean that motivations for seeking that knowledge out
are irrelevant because I think they are relevant. Uh
Absolutely the funding model. I mean, we're seeing
this right now with A I like most people can't
afford to build large language models there, there's this
whole thing of like elite capture and whether or not
we're going to have like a new monopoly of these
things, which is why we're getting a lot of
pushback and some people are wanting to release them as
source. Now. Uh What data goes into the
training sets, all of this stuff, the intellectual
property thereof. Can these things be audited or not
? And should they be particularly if they're involved in
public procurement of any kind? Um or like public
service use of any kind. So I think we're
sophisticated enough as a species where we can have this
conversation and go if you are doing something, if
you're seeking out knowledge and doing research on behalf of
shareholders for a company or a private company or the
government, governments are completely value laden. So of
course, it matters if you're doing it for the
US government versus the Chinese government versus let's pick Switzerland
which claims to be neutral, uh an interesting country
to tackle on that claim. Of course, these
things matter. So I feel like we can,
we can separate out the neutrality of the fact like
, oh wow, if you cut off my finger
, this is what happens like a finger being removed
from its hand produces X numbers of physical responses and
we can observe them and describe them forensically and repeat
that experiment and hopefully stop cutting people's fingers off because
we've, we've answered those questions. But why of
doing that? The who of doing that? The
, for what purpose are we going to use that
knowledge? Is it, you know, maybe we're
chopping our fingers for a really good reason. Maybe
we're doing it terribly just to be awful. Like
all of those questions are relevant and matter and we
can use them to, to do science potentially in
a more ethical way. And like, I know
that's a really problematic statement for a lot of people
. And it should be, I'm delighted that it's
a problematic statement because it means that our thinking is
like switched on and we're all going to go.
Does that mean to do more ethical science? What
does it mean to do ethical technology or ethical A
I? And we see that with A I,
right. I, I cannot think of another technology
where so many people have been in such a hurry
to claim that it's trustworthy, responsible, reliable,
um ethical, you know, we don't, we
don't feel the need to do that. And it's
because I think people understand we've matured enough as a
species to understand that A I is inherently not neutral
, that we have to rush out to brand it
as trustworthy or responsible because people are terrified. And
there's, you know, there's a reason for that
. There are some really scary uses, you could
put this technology to. So you need to reassure
people up front that, you know, we're just
using it for I don't know, whatever it is
. People want to be using it for, uh
, it seems to me again, largely for advertising
and marketing but there's a lot more, you know
, drug discovery would be a great one. But
even then, even then there could be, we
could discover some really trippy stuff with that and it's
gonna be, you know, what do we do
with it? What do we do with that knowledge
? You can't unknow something once you know it.
Mhm. Yeah. Uh, but I mean,
uh, explain a little bit better why in certain
instances, technology A I systems, for example,
can be biased. I mean, they can have
, for example, sexual racial bias or biases of
any other kind because there are people that, uh
, particularly when it comes, for example, to
how certain police departments in the US use systems to
, uh, fight against crime, I guess in
that way. And, uh, pe people,
uh, just rely on the data, those systems
generate and they say, oh, you're just feeding
them data and they are processing the data and then
they help, uh, the police. Uh,
uh, I, I mean, when it comes
to, uh, they have limited resources and they
have in terms of when, when it comes for
them to decide which particular areas they should police more
or less. So it's not biased at all.
It's just, uh, computer processing data. But
I, I mean, that's not really the case
. Oh, no. I mean, it's totally
biased. It is completely biased and like that's the
tricky thing. So you're right to highlight things like
facial recognition technology because that's going to be regulated under
the EU A I Act. And this whole question
of, can you just have real time identity surveillance
? Right. So people walking around like you see
in the movies and you and I'd be walking down
the street in a little square with a pair above
our head and it would be like, Stephanie her
, you know, Ricardo Lopez are walking down the
street going into a coffee shop and they would have
like our height and our weight and our eye color
, but potentially more, you know how we voted
in our last election, whether or not one of
us has credit cards and um you know, pick
your, pick your, your fantasy information profile about
yourself or your nightmare all about your political, you
know, our sexuality, uh you know, last
last pornography was looked at yesterday, right? Because
all that stuff is being tracked, all of it's
being track. Um So yes, that exists,
it's there. The eu is looking to take a
position not to do that. We use it here
in the United Kingdom where I'm talking to you from
the London Metropolitan Police loves facial recognition technology um for
reasons that are really bewildering because it doesn't seem to
improve their performance at all, but they insist on
using it. Um Despite parliament asking them repeatedly not
to. But that's what happens when you don't pass
laws making something, you know, banned or controlling
it. You just go, please don't do it
and the police just ignore it. In the US
. We've done a really different approach with that,
which is that certain cities or towns or states have
put into law rules about using it or not using
it and who can use it? Is it the
cops or do you also need to regulate private sector
use? Because one thing you could do is you
could ban the police from using it but allow the
private sector to carry on because remember, we must
upset the private sector in the US. But the
problem is the police can then just work around that
and buy the data or sometimes just get it for
free. But you know why get it for free
when someone can make money off of it. Uh
You can buy the data from a third party data
broker legally. So they're still getting the data and
we see this with Amazon Ring is a great example
of this. Uh people putting all those doorbells up
needing, needing to identify everybody have no idea that
that footage can actually just be taken by the cops
with nothing bumping it. So like well done for
participating in a surveillance society in your neighborhood. Uh
It's just, you know, it's just happening.
So that question sounds like well, so what?
Nothing to hide, nothing to fear. Right.
Like I'm not doing anything wrong. I don't care
if I'm being observed. I hear this all the
time and it's like, ok, cool. But
the problem is that this technology tends to perform better
on men with lighter skin and worst on women with
darker skin. So we've had a number of wrongful
arrests in the United States in which the police have
used facial recognition technology to make arrests like as part
of their arrest process and they have misidentified people who
were innocent. So these people get subject to really
traumatic arrests often in front of their family, they
might be held in custody for, you know,
36 92 hours, something horrific. Um, and
anybody who hasn't, you know, who thinks,
oh, that's not so bad has obviously never been
in a US police custody situation. It's not,
not something you would do voluntarily. Um, no
disrespect to law enforcement. It's just, it's not
, it's not nice to be treated as a suspected
criminal and particularly if you're innocent. And then there's
also the problem that there's no legal requirement in the
United States when you are, you know, when
you've been arrested and brought to trial, you don't
have to be told there's no requirement to protect you
telling you that facial recognition was used in your arrest
, which is really problematic for technology that doesn't work
very well. So that all of that is really
bad, but then people will go. Ok,
cool. So what we have to do to fix
all of those, you know, acknowledge risks.
It's really bad. Let's just pump it full of
more data. Refine, refine, refine and get
to a tool that works. It's never going to
work 100% of the time, but like with high
degree of accuracy, 99% of accuracy. So you're
like, all right, if you solve the accuracy
problem, have you solved the problem of facial recognition
? I personally have argued that you do not why
? Because now you've got your cameras that apparently are
pretty accurate everywhere because and we've seen this um in
the US is a great case in point. It
isn't just the cops who want it. People are
like, well, I I don't feel very confident
we've got high gun crime in the United States or
we're in schools or fill in the blank, whatever
your personal security concerns are, I'm going to get
a camera and put it everywhere. So now imagine
a United States in which private individuals have cameras in
their homes. Every business has cameras, cities get
in on the act because like we got, you
know, we'll do this to fight crime and you
now have it where people are being surveyed nonstop.
You would actually have to almost flip it and say
, where are they not being surveyed? Right?
And where is that data not being kept recorded?
Traded? You know who owns the cameras. So
here in the UK, we have a problem that
a lot of the CCTV cameras that we have all
over this country are very awkwardly sourced from China.
And so a big campaign has gone to rip them
out uh because this is now finally, finally being
deemed to be a security risk. And then the
question becomes ok. So is it the fact that
the camera is made by a Chinese company? Is
that the security risk or is the act of having
these cameras up at all a security risk? Like
, would you feel more comfortable if the camera making
it was a British company? Right? And I
think a lot of people to be completely frank would
they would be fine with that. Um For them
, the issue is, it's a, it's a
known hostile power. I mean, China has been
identified as a great one of the national security risks
to the UK. So you get into these situations
where you can just tell nobody thought this through because
, and you always have to do this. And
again, this is like my historian training, you
have to always imagine whatever system you're building in your
peaceful, liberal democratic happy country being weaponized if somebody
gets elected, who is awful. Now, the
classic example would be like, what if Hitler had
all of this tech, right? But you know
, let's not give that man any more um time
and attention that he's already had. You don't have
to go back to World War Two to look at
examples of countries that have become increasingly um how can
we say this, you know, cracking down on
women's reproductive rights that happened in the United States right
now, right? Like we don't, we don't
have to go to World War Two. We can
literally just open the newspaper today and see that women
who need to get abortions or to go to an
abortion clinic or a reproductive clinic simply to get health
advice are now being criminalized in several US states.
As are the people that help them, their friends
, their mothers, whatever. And that was something
that has always been a threat. But then I
think most people, if you had said before,
Roe versus Wade was, was challenged um successfully.
If you had told them this could be a risk
, they would have looked at you like you were
some crazy feminist. Well, here you are crazy
feminist. It's happened, it's happened. And so
you've got your phone data, all of your internet
data, right? So Facebook has had problems.
Meta has had problems because they've been handing over data
to cops, to arrest women who need to go
and get an abortion. And if you had told
somebody that when Facebook came on the scene in the
mid two thousands, they would not have believed you
. I'm sure that Mark Zuckerberg and his designing crew
never thought that that would be a risk because no
one imagined the US political context changing in that way
. You can imagine it with the Lbgtqi A plus
community which again is constantly under threat, not just
in the US, but like everywhere, in terms
of their right to get married, their right to
adopt, um just their right to not be like
harassed and persecuted on the street. You are now
going to have all of this surveillance equipment that potentially
can be put in the hands of a democratically elected
government that is bad, right? And bad in
the sense of like would prosecute them, persecute them
. And that's, you know, that's my view
. That's bad. I know there's people that would
disagree with that and I don't care. I bet
, I bet that the Center in Florida would love
that. Yeah. No, they absolutely would love
it. They would love it. So, like
, you just, you have to design for that
in mind and that's where like sci fi training and
like a very good, healthy uh background in literature
and cinema can be really helpful because it helps you
to imagine scenarios that will seem crazy at the time
and be like, yeah, but what if,
how many steps away or again, like, and
that's why one of the chapters in my book is
, where do you draw the line? I'm like
, how many steps do you have before your liberal
democracy turns into like fascism or simply authoritarianism? Or
like a Christian theocracy or whatever, it doesn't have
to be Christian. It could be any religion.
But like that matters and those rights that we have
in so many liberal democracies are so precious and they
have been so fought and hard won and they're also
so easily taken away. And that's where you must
know your history because if you don't know history,
someone will say, yeah. But you know,
you're just worrying about nothing and you need to be
able to go. No, this has already happened
or it happened in this way. And actually here
in this case, we're only, you know,
it would only take two or three steps for us
to enter that world. So how do I design
for that? I mean, a really good strategist
and a really good technology designer, technology ethicist can't
simply rely on a technological background. You must have
the social sciences and you know, liberal arts and
humanities training as well. I think it's one of
the toughest jobs to do actually. And that's no
disrespect to engineering colleagues or more sort of classically trained
stem colleagues. Their, their work is also extremely
challenging and difficult. But there there's something especially hard
about the human component, right? People don't use
things that necessarily the way they were intended or they
modify them because again, it's just in our nature
. So you have to always design with the worst
in mind. And that means you have to have
incredible knowledge and a really good imagination and like a
humility to think about your own blind spots, right
? Which is why you don't want monocultural teams.
You have to have people with really different experiences and
those different views have to be really respected because those
people will help you see risk that you would just
miss you. You won't hear it, you won't
see it. You need somebody else who's like,
I know what this is like because I am of
this community or I'm from this country and I saw
this or my, my country lived through this.
Um That's, that's a tough one. But uh
you mentioned uh sci-fi there. Uh And I mean
, I, I understand all of your arguments but
II, I have to say that at least to
some extent and unless I'm un I'm misunderstanding what you're
saying there about sci fi, I might have some
issue with people uh real uh looking into or relying
on. I don't know, something that is portrayed
in a sci fi movie or sci fi book when
it comes to uh worrying about the potential dangers of
technology A I or something like that. Because um
I mean, for example, if you think that
uh the things you should be worried about are I
don't know, a terminator like scenarios or West world
like scenarios where technology suddenly becomes sentient and develops their
own uh motives and goals and all of that and
suddenly wants to wipe out humanity or perhaps, uh
, the next day we have to be worried about
, uh, mistreating, uh A I systems because
they might be sentient and all of that. I
mean, I just worry that, uh, if
people take those kinds of scenarios too seriously, they
might distract, that might help distract them from the
actual more realistic issues that might derive from technology.
You know? I mean, do you understand what
I'm worried about here? I completely understand it.
And that's been a concern that a lot of people
have raised in the past couple of months ever since
people started writing those letters saying we should have a
pause and A I research and warning of the different
risks that it presents on an existential societal level.
And that group of people who are worried about existential
risks of A I have been accused of worried about
something that may never happen because it's not really a
I that they're worried about, they're worried about artificial
general intelligence, which is a different beast in the
sense that that's, that's the moment that again,
it's hypothetical, it has not happened and it may
never happen. But in theory, it's the moment
when smart machines become smarter than human beings. I
love how I said that and the dog just that's
hilarious. The robot dog, um smart machines,
when, when these machines become more intelligent than us
as a species and like, what would they do
to us is the big fear and there is a
concern that that's distracting from what I guess you could
call now. Risks, risks you could have now
, risks or even near future quite of, you
know, it's either it's happening now and here is
, you know, the risk of discrimination in like
how A I is used in healthcare, how A
I is used in the medical or sorry, the
legal profession or risks of misinformation and disinformation in terms
of elections and journalism and like public confidence in the
integrity of how the the citizen state relationship works.
That's all happening or selling your online data, for
example, selling your online data, gathering your data
. I mean, like literally a month doesn't go
by when meta isn't being fined for some sort of
data violation and they just, you know, they
just price it in and everybody is there. It's
incredible to me, but they do. Um So
that's all happening now and then you're right to identify
like near term risks, which is like we're not
quite there as a risk. Perhaps a good example
, perhaps a good example of that would be certain
genetic engineering technologies. I mean, we're not really
there yet, but it's probably in the near future
. So yeah, you could come up with,
I'm sure a number of different categories to kind of
like, you know, make columns if you will
. So definitely need to worry about this now because
it's already happening likely to happen soon, but we're
not there yet. And here's the conditions that we
would have to fulfill to get there versus like may
never happen. But if they did call them low
probability, high impact events, um egag I takes
over um and what will they do to us and
turn us into slaves or something? So, you
know, is that distracting is your question? I
think, I don't know. First of all,
I don't think that you're going to get, I
don't think it's like helpful to tell people not to
think about something because they're going to think about it
. It's like, you know, that, that
experiment of don't think of the white polar bear.
You know, as I'm telling you to do this
, your brain is like all I can think of
is a white polar bear. So I think,
I think first of all, it's actually probably I'm
not the cognitive psychologist, but my guess would be
the easiest thing to do is actually to name it
. Like do what we just did be like,
there's these different types of risks. The one that
the media really loves to go for is the one
that's actually the least likely why do they like to
go for it? Because it's great storytelling. We've
actually, we've literally seen this movie before. So
I talk with clients a lot and I've got a
presentation that I've been using the past couple of months
that it is really like driven people wild in a
good way that is looking at cinema and we talk
about the different ways that A I appears in cinema
over time and it's so effective because you have,
you can't have a conversation about A I without naming
Terminator, you just can't. So I make it
the first slide. I'm like, let's, let's
name it, let's dismantle it and deconstruct it like
a bomb, you know, take it apart and
neutralize it if you will and then talk about why
it's so resonant. Everybody has a really good laugh
and this kind of like looks around like, you
know, I'm not the only one who thinks about
Terminator. No, we all think about Terminator.
Why is that? And then you move on,
you would maybe talk about the matrix, you might
talk about Blade Runner. Um You can talk about
Westworld, you could talk about black mirror, right
? So you go through all the different things that
are in popular culture and you also look at the
imagery, right? So it's not just the story
, it's the picture. So like the Terminator,
what's quite terrifying about the Terminator is he's both human
. Uh although he's like a superman, she's,
it's Arnold Schwarzenegger, but he's also when he like
rips off all of his fleshy bits. He is
made the designer who is very cleverly in the movie
, made it to look like a human technological skeleton
. So it's like a metal head. It's literally
a metal skull and it has teeth, like it
has actual human teeth and you're like, why,
like, why does it need human teeth? It's
a robot. It does not need. So what
is that about? And the reason is because it's
terrifying, right? It's really scary. If you
saw that when you were a kid, you were
like unable to not ever see it again. So
you have to think about why that is or like
the image of um like a human hand kind of
going like that to another human hand. And it's
, it's, it's riffing off of Michelangelo's Sistine chapel
, right of God touching Adam and giving the spark
of life. And you'll see that, that image
a lot when we talk about A I because it's
a really useful shorthand visually for us to think about
, you know, God God, something that people
call like God in the judeo-christian sense with that picture
created humans. And so then they'll riff on it
and you'll see another image of a human hand touching
a robot finger, right? Like it's going like
that. And then in this case, humans have
become God and the robot is our creation. And
that taps into one of the best science fiction films
of all time or movies or books around of all
time, which is of course, Mary Shelley's Frankenstein
, like this idea that you can, you can
create it and then it goes rogue and it's a
fascinating piece of literature uh that I think captured something
in, again humans because we create things all the
time and it's this sort of primal fear of what
happens when our creations come back and like kill us
, which probably actually is about like parents with their
Children, right? Like it's in a really demented
way. But I'm talking, I'm talking subconscious stuff
, right? Stuff that works across all societies that
there's that fear of your creation getting out of control
because that, that's a narrative that we know we
recognize it uh across time. So you have to
, I think you actually, it's a wasted amount
of energy to tell people don't think about these things
. It's distracting. I think it's actually more effective
to think about it right up front. Name it
have a chat together, build everybody's critical thinking and
images on the news. Whenever you talk about A
I, I do a lot of work with the
media. When I go on television, it will
be a split screen. It will be me talking
about A I with a bunch of books in the
background, hopefully saying intelligent things and then the images
that they put on the other side of the screen
to illustrate A I are like on drugs, they're
like hallucinatory acid trips. It'll be like it'll be
like a light sort of floating. You know,
like when people say they, they almost die and
they have like a near death experience, they're in
a, they're in a white tunnel going towards the
light, they'll show something like that, then they'll
show like a video game graphic of a human head
from the neck up. That's completely translucent. You
can see right through it. And inside is a
human brain glowing orange and it's like rotating around and
it's like floating on a magic carpet, like a
video game version of a magic carpet. Why?
Because I'm assuming it's because they're like, oh if
we're talking about artificial intelligence, we have to show
what do we think of intelligence, you think of
a brain? So we'll show the, we'll show
the viewers a brain but like a like a sci
fi version of a brain. It's not like an
actual brain because an actual brain is a bit gross
, right? It's sort of the biological wet thing
. So they show you instead an abstraction of a
brain and then they might show the finger image,
right? Like they, they riff on weird stuff
and once you see this or you'll see like lots
of zeros and ones raining down, right? Like
in the matrix. And there's a reason for that
. They're not, this is not an accident.
These things are highly iconic images from the films and
shows that we've all seen. So they become a
visual shorthand. So you can't, I just think
you can't ignore this stuff. I think you actually
have to go right at it straight at it.
Discuss it and then you can if you want per
it and go, let's actually look at the stuff
that is perhaps less visually sexy, right? Less
visually interesting to show which is going to be predictive
policing algorithms, facial recognition, technology discrimination. Um
banks using A I to decide if you can get
a mortgage or not. Right? Like that,
that is less sci-fi sexy. It's less scary,
but it's actually most people's experience of A I.
So that's fascinating. Most people don't realize how A
I is already being used on them, right?
Like I think they would be appalled if they did
. So that's, I think the media's challenge and
the challenge of writers and analysts and people are trying
to educate the public is like you're going to need
a visual iconography if you will a visual language and
you're going to need a narrative language for storytelling that
makes those real risks, risks that are right now
as compelling as the ones that are more hypothetical,
but that we've all been seeing in shows and movies
for decades now. Right? So it's a,
again, so many things with technology are actually about
culture, right? They're about the human relationship with
technology. So like getting people involved and caring about
something like A I which, you know, we're
in a cost of living crisis here in the UK
, good luck going out onto the streets of Brazil
. I guess the Portugal getting people to care,
I guess that across the entire room we're living through
a cost of living crisis. Yeah. Right.
So, if you're like, you know, do
you want to have this chat? People are like
, no, because I'm too busy, like,
dealing with massive inflation or, like very high interest
rates or unemployment or climate change, like, you
know, half of Europe as we were just discussing
under a massive heat dome and sweltering away. So
, getting them to think about A I is tricky
. So you have to help them, you have
to make that really easy for them to do.
And so that's where I really enjoy this kind of
work because I've noticed the effect that it has on
people when you take them through some of the concepts
that we've just been discussing is they're like, oh
my God, I see this everywhere. Now I
see those images everywhere. I see. The media
loves to go to some stories and then not to
others. Why is that? You have to look
at their incentive structure. What do they get measured
on clicks, viewing figures, et cetera. So
the scarier they can make the story. So why
any time Elon Musk does everything, the media loves
it because it's, he's there in some sort of
symbiotic relationship, right? He says something outrageous,
they cover it and go, isn't it outrageous?
He then is like, I hate the press,
you know, the world weirdest dysfunctional relationship ever.
But people who are doing like really important work on
A I are not getting that kind of media coverage
, right? And they maybe don't talk the way
that Elon Musk talks, they won't give examples or
say things that are really outrageous to get attention.
If you're a really measured, considered scientist or researcher
, you're not going to say something that's very Clickbait
. Yeah. And by the way, since you
mentioned that, let's talk a little bit more about
social media because it's not only the misinformation issue but
also in terms of these discussions surrounding the supposed neutrality
of technology. I mean, if you just look
at social media, it's ply obvious that there's no
neutrality there at all because I, I mean,
even what you get mostly exposed to, it's just
what they decide to boost to get more views,
clicks, likes whatever and usually it's the most outrageous
stuff out there, right? And lies. I
mean, there's fascinating research about how lies spread much
faster than facts on the internet and like, yeah
, now we're in this world where so much of
it can be faked. Um not just imagery and
video footage but sound audio. So you're going to
have this thing where people are going to find it
very, very difficult to know what is real and
not real. I don't know, I sometimes think
that we may be approaching if not the end of
social media, it definitely a new phase. Um
Are, you know, do people do people really
want to go online and see their friends talking about
holidays and babies and lunch, which was a lot
of how social media was from the mid two thousands
onward. And now it seems to be kind of
invaded by content creators, you know, influencers and
the like, and then if you start feeling like
, oh my God, if I go on,
it's actually manipulating me, that's not good either.
And there's all the mental health research of, you
know, lots of people who spend time on social
media end up feeling really depressed or anxious. Um
, and it can feel really toxic for many,
many people just to go on. It could be
awful. I just wonder, I don't know.
I'm, I'm thinking aloud here, but I do
wonder if there's just going to be a bunch of
people for whom this start to just feel really irrelevant
because it's kind of like, I don't know the
way that television, I just came back from the
US and I'm always just stunned by American television.
Now, the amount of advertising that you are just
bombarded with and it's, you know, if you're
not used to it, if you are in a
country where you don't have a lot of advertising in
your TV, you just kind of look at your
American family and friends and you're like, you're just
being like brainwashed with all of this all the time
and that's how social media feels like my Twitter feed
feed. Since Elon Musk took over, it's just
full of, no, but since you talk about
that, about American television, let me just tell
you that I'm a wrestling fan and so I watch
wrestling mostly from the US, of course, because
it's the, the biggest place for wrestling in the
world. But, uh, I mean, I
, I really notice that, uh, if you
watched wrestling, like, 20 years ago you would
have the matches and then a few breaks with advertisements
and all of that. But, but now you
get split screens where there's, uh, uh,
a tiny window with the match and then next,
with the advertisement. And I'm like, oh man
, I want to watch the match. I don't
care about pizzas and burgers and whatever. Let me
change. I thought when I go to the cinema
and it's like, I'm just here to see the
movie and ideally the previews and I feel like I
pay quite a lot to go to the cinema and
then you have to sit through, you know,
20 minutes of adverts, but then you work it
out and so you just show up later, right
? So if you want, there's ways, there's
always ways of hacking, there's probably some way of
like hacking your wrestling channel to only see the WS
about the ads. But I just, I guess
I'm just saying that I feel like these things evolve
and like social media for a while clearly had some
sort of utility. It helps people feel connected clearly
. But then it started to have, what would
you call it if it's not utility? I was
gonna say negative utility. But, you know,
again, like, it has a cost to it
and I guess you're constantly weighing up in life.
Is the pain worth the pleasure. Right. Like
, is it, is it full? And I
just think for a lot of people, I mean
, I've heard constantly is this the end of Twitter
? And like, I'm very mixed because I use
Twitter for instance, for my work quite a lot
. But part of me was like, maybe the
best thing that could happen to me is that Twitter
, like, failed and tried because I'm not on
other than linkedin, I'm not on any other social
media channel. I managed to like, break all
of those addictions and habits from my youth. Um
, Twitter is like the last holdout and in a
way it would just do me a huge favor if
it just wasn't even an option, which is a
really, that, that's a weird feeling to have
. On the one hand, I miss the old
days of Twitter because I had a lot of fun
. I made amazing contacts and friends on it and
it was really helpful to me for my work.
But I do feel that it's, it's just,
it's not a very nice place. It's like going
into, I was in Frankfurt airport a couple of
weeks ago and they have like an old fashioned smoking
lounge in the airport and it's like a glass cage
for smokers. And if you're a non smoker,
which I am you're walking by, you see all
these people in, you know what looks basically like
a cancer room. You know, they all smoking
and like, you just look at them and you're
like, my God, it's expensive. It's dangerous
. It's stinky. Like you, you're going to
come out of there. Absolutely reeking. It's a
, but the, but like the compassion kicks in
because it's one of the hardest addictions to kick.
But, but rarely do you see it that way
? And I kind of wonder if we're getting to
the point where, where some people can either see
themselves in the social media equivalent of the smoking lounge
in Frankfurt Airport and be like, why are you
doing this to yourself? Like if these things make
you feel so bad, why do you go on
them if you feel the news is unreliable or you
just get shouted out by crazy people you've never met
? Why are you signing up for an emotional beating
? Like there's other ways to get your news that
are probably more reliable and that don't involve that.
So, you know, all of us I think
are going to have a real and probably are already
having, um, a sort of reckoning with a
new relationship. And I think that could be a
real challenge for the social media companies is if you
just got a mass movement of people who were like
, you know what, this isn't worth it anymore
. Yeah, that's hard. But by the way
, uh related to that about collecting data online and
selling people's data because there are people out there that
are perhaps still not sold on this idea that they
should care about this because they're just like, oh
, come on, I go on the internet and
I go on Facebook and just, uh, see
some of the news and uh share a few silly
stuff. I mean, uh stuff related to my
vacation or something like that, my kids and perhaps
I watch some vanilla porn and go on Amazon and
buy some stuff. I mean, what, what's
the big deal with their collecting that, that date
, uh uh uh the, the, the update
and then selling it to other people? I mean
, I'm not doing anything bad than with the I
, I'm not overwhelmed on the internet with ads that
I don't really care about because they're also catering to
the things that, that I tend to like.
So what's the big deal there? So there's so
many ways we could tackle that. I guess one
that I would start out with is like, can
they imagine like, can they literally conceive of a
world in which they aren't having all of their data
gathered? Because like, that's an option, right
? That's a design choice. That we've all made
, we could have a world in which you can't
track me from site to site to site or which
third party brokers aren't, are like, just not
allowed to exist much less traffic in our data for
profit. Um And it's true like I struggle with
this because I think most people have just priced in
that they're going to have their data involved in a
data hack or leak at some point. And like
, what's the worst that happens to them is maybe
a little bit of casual identity theft, perhaps a
bit of fraud, uh which hopefully their banks will
cover, right? So if you look at where
the incentives are to care about this, I don't
know how much it is on the individual banks care
about it because they want to stop fraud. Um
Governments care about it because they also need to stop
identity fraud for all sorts of security reasons. But
like do individuals care and I I'm with you.
I think the example that you just gave of the
person who's like going through the journey of sharing their
data is kind of a personal preference. Um At
this point, some people really care about it.
Other people don't, I think you could make it
more of like a consumer protection competition issue to say
I don't even really have a choice so I might
care about it. But the regulators aren't doing a
good enough job because there's no way for me to
have options to choose to create an online experience for
myself because I have to be online that doesn't involve
this. But there's also the whole factor. The
whole question in mind of so much of how we've
allowed everything to work is for free, but it
isn't really for free because your data is the,
is the product that's being trafficked and traded for a
profit. If you remove that, do I have
to pay to compensate for it? Right. So
if I want to have ad free listening on my
favorite podcast, that option exists, but I have
to join the podcast and pay a subscription because fair
enough the podcast creators like have bills to pay as
well and they're like, listen, we either get
paid from ads or subscription, you decide. And
like, that's what was interesting with Twitter is I
think Elon Musk tried to go down that path by
getting people to pay, you know,8 a
month to be verified because he was, he was
saying he wanted to do it that way, which
was slightly flawed because Twitter's revenue model was largely advertising
based as it is for indeed most of the platforms
. And the subscription model doesn't really seem to work
with any of those. And it's also really difficult
to get people to pay for something they've had for
free for a really long time. Howls of protest
. Uh People don't even want to pay for good
journalism. So you'll constantly see people bitching online going
. This article is behind a paywall. Not understanding
. I guess they don't understand the cost of good
journalism and not like reporters have to be paid.
Editors have to be paid. Uh, they just
, they just want it for free. So people
always want stuff for free and they won't pay for
it. So I think in that case for,
for the majority of people like that, they won't
care. And I'm not, to be honest,
I'm not even sure that they should care, which
is a controversial statement to make because they have almost
no power to get it fixed. I think the
people who do have power and who do care who
have like an incentive to care are the big companies
looking to bust fraud and they lobby like mad.
So they could actually lobby for a safer internet if
they wanted to. And in fact, instead what
they're doing is just upping the amount of, you
know, anti fraud protections that you would have to
use when you're doing online banking. For instance,
you might get like a, you know, you'll
buy something online and then you'll get a code to
your phone from your bank checking that you actually wanted
to make this purchase, right? Like that's a
new mechanism or getting people to have multi factor authentication
to check that it's really them doing something. So
we haven't, we haven't come up with, with
a way around this. And I think that's because
again, the ultimate extreme example of risk is you
build this massive surveillance capitalism model or the Chinese social
system, social credit system model of surveillance in the
liberal democratic world. We haven't yet had unfortunately a
pretty grim test run which would be a bad government
getting elected into power who then weaponizes all of the
information that's gathered on all of us. And because
humans seem to need to see risks before they can
decide to. Then, oh God, we better
fix that and make sure that doesn't happen again.
It's very difficult for them to think ahead and prevent
something from happening. I don't see that going away
anytime soon. It would be really nice if we
did because honestly, the cost to society of fraud
and identity theft is massive and we have a new
generation, new generation uh that's been coming on really
since the early two thousands, who all of their
life so much of their life, more than any
other human in history is online. So the,
the risk is not proportionate if you're a baby boomer
and the majority of your life is not online.
If your generation z almost all of it is or
not all of it. That's unfair. That's an
exaggeration. Um, let's just call it. Well
, I mean, I can tell you, I
can tell you that I have a little brother who
is 10 years, 10 years younger than me.
And he's basically lived with internet his entire life.
I mean, I started using internet when I was
9, 10 years old, but he lived with
internet, been posting pictures of them for years,
you know, that they have an internet presence that
they weren't even aware of. I mean, that
you can create all sorts of existential um, angst
and emotional problems about privacy and sharing and who's,
who has to share your image or your story or
your information. That's probably another reason that we haven't
really evolved yet is I think when as that generation
comes of age and they are coming of age now
, um and only will continue to do so,
they may have different views on this. Whereas I
think for the baby boomers and possibly generation X even
who are largely in positions of power, it hasn't
affected them as much. It'd be interesting like to
talk with your little brother or indeed anybody who's of
that younger generation to feel. I think they are
really different notions of privacy and culture around sharing and
consent. So on the one hand, they have
less privacy, but I think they're also much more
alive to this question of consent and what that means
and why the consent model doesn't even always work.
I still though I still come down to, I
think it's a very old school problem. I think
regulators have really failed on competition because if you don't
want to be tracked by Facebook, um, across
the internet. It just doesn't matter that the,
the regulatory fines, well, they can pay the
fines like that. That model has to be updated
to deal with giants who can afford to pay fines
and actually really happy to do that. As long
as you don't interfere with their operating model, what
we actually have to do is make it so that
it can't do that legally in the first place.
You know, if Mark Zuckerberg literally faced criminal charges
and could like do jail time for that, I'm
sure he would change his model, but since he
just has to write a check, yeah, I
mean, because those fines, they don't hurt their
profits at all. Let's be real completely. I
mean, in fact, I still remember with horror
, the FTC had issued what was then the biggest
fine against Facebook for privacy violations and Facebook share price
went up, didn't hurt them, it went up
. Why did it go up? It went up
because people had been worried that the FTC might actually
take action on their data gathering practices, but they
didn't. So they were like super, if you're
, if you're telling me that all you're going to
do is find me, then I can build that
into my financial modeling, call it, call it
a tax pay it and carry on which is what
they do. And so that's going to be,
the question is like, we were talking about threads
with, with meta coming up with this new social
media platform to rival Twitter and the like. And
I was fascinated by how many people signed up and
we're talking about it. It was like, have
you forgotten who is behind all of this? These
are the same people who were complaining when Francis Hagen
blew the whistle on mental health abuses by Facebook Instagram
on Children. And they're the same people who freaked
out when Facebook was involved with Cambridge Analytica in rigging
the US election in 2016. You know, all
thinking that Mark Zuckerberg is, is awful. But
as soon as he put this out because he's not
Elon Musk and it became the thing like they had
a total memory wipe and they, and they all
signed up not thinking, I wonder why this isn't
allowed to be released in the European Union yet,
right? So like we were just talking about the
fact that you can't get it there because the amount
of data that threads harvests is huge and we know
that these people are not going to be using it
for good, they're using it for profit and yet
people signed up. So like that was again,
as a a technology ethicist, I was fascinated because
I was like all that you can give people all
the information in the world and they will still make
bad choices. It's just not, it's not enough
to give them information and it's not enough to remind
them again and again and again, that need to
have a social media life, uh seems to be
really strong in a lot of people. We saw
it first with Mastodon, then we saw the blue
sky now its threads like it's, it's this thing
and it never seems to get the critical mass that
, that may have changed by the time this podcast
go out, um they'll have a spike in early
adoption and then it kind of falls off. And
that's what I mean about kind of looking to the
long term is like, are people actually going to
want this? Because what, what need does it
serve and is the price too high to pay?
Yeah, very fascinating. But I don't know.
But by the way, since uh earlier, you
mentioned that you wrote your book during the COVID-19 pandemic
, I would also like to ask you what,
what is your idea about uh some of the digi
digital health tools that were used during the COVID-19 pandemic
because of course, we were dealing with a major
health issue and perhaps even if there with some data
collection, uh I, I mean, it,
it would still be ethical to do that. The
pros would outweigh the cons because of the threat we
were dealing with. But what do you think about
uh some of the data that were potentially collected by
, I guess governments mostly during that period? It's
interesting, isn't it like we haven't really had all
of the different countries that built that kind of health
surveillance tech if you will um come out as a
group, I don't mean individually but as a group
or through the auspices of the, who the World
Health Organization to say, like if we have another
pandemic, God forbid in, you know, a
few years time, is this a tool that we
want to have in our toolbox Eg was it effective
or not? And not only was it effective?
Was it worth it? Which is a different question
? Um The UK has had some studies that came
out arguing that it reduced transmission. But II I
still question some of that because we can't really run
a couple of other sort of counterfactual experiments. Like
what, what would it be like if we hadn't
used it? There's a lot of problems still with
some of the things that I cook. And I
also just think I interviewed loads of doctors while I
was writing that chapter and none of them were asking
for this. Like this was not the tool,
this was not the mitigation that they need, that
they felt they needed. Um The most effective mitigations
were the lockdowns unfortunately. And then obviously the big
one was vaccines, but doctors weren't calling for this
. It really felt for me like a solution in
search of a problem in the sense that this massive
crisis happened. Technologists wanted to do something investors saw
a potential to make money from it and like,
Voila, let's go for it. And you saw
in the case of Singapore, um, they said
at first we, you know, we're making this
mandatory, but don't worry, we're going to collect
data that we would never use for like a criminal
policing aspect. We're only using it for public health
and of course they did use it for the criminal
policing aspect. So, like, not a surprise
, like, saw that one coming a mile away
. And absolutely, I think the UK would have
done it. I mean, we've seen, unfortunately
, we're going through our COVID inquiry now and it's
been pretty grim, the behavior of people in power
. Uh, certainly within our current government, a
lot of the ministers who were not following their own
laws or, you know, they were, the
police were really clamping down and there was like a
certain people were more heavily policed than others and there
was a racial, ethnic class component to that,
right. So you do that and then you put
technology solutions on top of that. I just think
you're going to create some really serious problems. The
parliament hadn't really created pandemic legislation in place to deal
with it. And part of the reason, um
, I put my book out in February of 2022
and that was because I was in my poor publishers
. I was like, we have to wait because
they started passing legislation I think it was to remember
now, the last order England was the last one
to create a legal framework to allow these, to
allow these apps which had already been in existence for
like a year at that point, maybe even more
. Um They didn't have a legal framework for it
though in the four nations of the United Kingdom until
starting in September of 2021. And then England was
the last one in December of 2021. So I
was typing against the clock because I wanted to capture
that before we went to press uh and put it
out to show really, the UK had, had
completely changed its position. We used to be a
country that was super proud of not having identity cards
and all of a sudden in this case, we
did and we've also put them in for voting now
, by the way, like massive cultural shift here
, not without protest. So they did that.
And then within like two months of England passing that
law, they basically were like, we're not using
the app anymore. Why? Because it wasn't like
it wasn't effective, it was not what, what
was needed. So we did all of this mass
, you know, they blew a huge amount of
political capital and wasted loads of time on something that
they in the end themselves decided it wasn't going to
be a requirement. And what was really awful in
that is they kept lying about it. So they
kept saying, hey, we're not building it when
they were secretly building it, then they were like
, well, we're building it but it's not going
to be mandatory and blah, blah, blah.
So each time they kind of destroyed public trust,
which is essential in something like a national crisis or
international crisis, like a pandemic. So, you
know, my takeaway for what it's worth and stuff
like that is, you know, a I'm not
convinced it was worth it scientifically and medically, it
wasn't what healthcare professionals certainly were calling for. Um
The risks are super high in terms of potential for
abuse and they blew so much political and social trust
and that matters in a democracy because if we,
you know, I guarantee you, if we go
again into another pandemic, a lot of people are
going to remember all the lying that government did trust
matters when you're handing over data, trust matters.
If you're doing surveillance and trust matters in terms of
health and because you, you're talking to people about
their bodies, ultimately, you know, you play
with that with your peril. So that for me
was the real learning point was like, how do
I create trust in the scientific method in health care
? You're asking people to make massive sacrifices, you
have to be even more trustworthy than normal because you're
, you're, you're making a bigger, ask a
bigger demand and for my two cents for what it's
worth in the UK. We blew that. We
absolutely blew it. Um So it wouldn't be great
to, to have to have, you know,
run that experiment again. If there's, you know
, pandemic version 2.0 I would have a lot of
confidence and I suspect the US would be the same
. I mean, that was another case, my
family and friends over in America, they were like
there was no case of requiring people to use that
kind of surveillance technology for health, for better or
for worse. And you can look at the outcomes
on that. But that's what I'm talking about.
The technology is just one part of it. There's
the cultural bit about adaptation. Why were certain European
countries were happy to do it? And others weren't
certain countries could afford to do it or have the
infrastructure, do it? Certain populations have an iphone
or an Android and others just don't. So it's
not even an option for them, right? Like
all of those things come into play. And if
you're looking at utilitarianism, if you're looking at like
the greatest number of happiness for the greatest numbers of
people, you might want to do. What I
was trying to do is go back to the original
problem set and go what is it that the healthcare
profession says it needs, it needs P pe they
thought they needed ventilators that later was dismissed because to
be honest, by the point, you're on a
ventilator. It's pretty bad. Um, they needed
people to stay home and they really needed a race
for a vaccine. That is where you want to
put, given that you have limited capital and limited
resources. That's where you want to go. But
people were super excited with this idea that this app
on our phone is going to allow us to open
up society again. Yeah. No, no,
I have to tell you here in Portugal, the
government also put out an app in 2021 if I'm
not mistaken. And back then they were moralizing people
a lot. Oh, you should install the app
, blah, blah, blah, blah, it's
a health measure, whatever. Uh And I,
and I was like, so first of all,
I never installed the app because it was not mandatory
. So I myself never installed the app at all
. Uh But, but first of all, I
was like, yeah, and if certain people do
not even have smartphones to begin with, I mean
, are you also going to moralize those people?
I mean, no one should be forced to have
a smartphone if they have one of those older,
uh, cell phones, I mean, who cares
? And, and then, and then I was
like, I was taking the pandemic very serious.
I was masking all the time. I was staying
at home as much as possible. Uh I was
distancing as much as possible. I got tested two
or three times during the pandemic. It always came
out negative. Fortunately, uh and I was like
, doing everything apart from the app and I was
like, ok, if I'm doing all of this
, let's say that I uh cross paths with someone
who also has the app installed and I get an
alert on my phone saying that I uh went by
uh for uh was less than 3 m or whatever
away from a person who got diagnosed with COVID.
Yeah. What am I going to do with that
? Because let's get real if I, even if
I get COVID, but I'm a symptomatic, I'm
not going to get tested. Let's get real.
So I, I mean, what, how uh
valuable is that information for me? And, and
I, and if I am COVID negative, no
, no uh no one out there who goes by
me will get any alert saying that they crossed paths
with someone who has COVID. So, I mean
, and I got vaccinated as soon as possible.
So what, what can I gain or anyone who
crosses perhaps with me can gain from this? And
I never though because like, like the, the
sort of wanna be scientist in me is like,
I'm glad that we tried it because like, I
understand in those pre vaccine days, like people were
like, we have to try whatever we can.
That's understandable. Um I'm glad we tried it in
a number of different countries with different political and cultural
flavors. So, that we could see like what
words or what might not work because we don't know
again, uh wherever the next pandemic will come from
, we don't know when that will happen and where
it will be with our technology. That's kind of
why I was really motivated to write the chapters.
Like I want to capture the UK case study to
the best of my ability now, not just the
tech part but the social cultural part. Because if
this happens again, you know, when it happened
for us in 2020 I was going back to books
on the Spanish flu. In 1918, I was
like, I need, you know, I need
, I need to skill up fast. What do
I need to know about this? And I'm sure
loads of people felt the same way just as ordinary
citizens. You don't have to be a researcher to
be interested in, you know, learning what had
happened in previous pandemics, but I wanted to create
something so that future future researchers could go back and
be like, well, what happened in the UK
? And you know, I'm sure loads of people
have written stuff on that um for what it's worth
, I will share this, the Ada Lovelace Institute
here in the United Kingdom is a wonderful research institution
and they've just come out with their assessment of pandemic
technology. I haven't had a chance to read it
yet because I just came back from holiday. But
it looks pretty interesting and they do great work.
So that might be something for your viewers to check
out if they want to. I feel like the
Turing Institute might have as well. Um And definitely
Oxford University has published a lot of stuff on it
, but I'm intrigued by the ada Lovelace view because
they often do an international comparison. So there is
cutting edge research that I am unfortunately behind on at
the moment. But you know, we know it's
there. So if anyone wants to take a look
at that, if you don't want to hear what
I have to say by all means, don't go
check out in a lovely, they got some good
stuff and I mean, just to be clear,
I'm not completely dismissing these apps. I'm not saying
100% that they didn't help at all that they weren't
good health measures. I'm just saying that first of
all, no one should be forced to have a
smartphone. That's the first point. Second of all
, you shouldn't moralize people for not having a smartphone
or install, really should moralize them when you're the
British ministers who were breaking all of their own rules
. Yeah, that's one thing to moralize if you
at least to walk the walk. But if you're
doing hypocrisy, like get out and, and then
my first and then the third point and that's why
I mentioned that I really follow all the guidelines and
all of that to prevent COVID transmission is that you
have to convince me that it's worth it because I'm
not dumb and people are not dumb. Don't,
don't treat us as dumb like, oh, you
should do this. Yeah. Why, why you
have with anything? If you're asking people to make
a change, you have to show them why it
is worth it. Listen, I'm just aware of
the fact that it's approaching 11. I'm going to
have to let you go if that's ok because I
unfortunately have to talk to one of my clients.
Oh, yeah. No, no, sorry.
I, I, I love this chat but I
was like, oh, no, the time has
flown. No, no, I'm sorry, I
wasn't aware that you had that time limit. So
, yeah. So just quickly before we go,
would you like to tell people where they can find
you and your work on the internet? Well,
I mean, I'm a Google search away. Uh
, probably the easiest is my website, which is
Habra, uh, Hare brain.co. So you can
find all my, uh, television and radio and
online writing. Um, and paper writing there.
My book is available at all good bookstores. You
can just order it through your local independent bookstore or
Pay Il Amazon. It's up to you your call
, not mine how you want to do it.
So it's there. It's an audio book too if
you prefer to listen to it rather than read it
. But then you'll miss the amazing date, this
, which is in the book. So it just
depends on what you want. Um And I'm on
Twitter and linkedin in case anybody has questions or wants
to follow up or share something that they think I've
missed or that I need to look at. I'm
really, really lucky for some reason, I have
an incredible group of people from the public who just
send me stuff randomly tips and things to look at
or articles that are actually really interesting or examples from
their country that I would never have heard about otherwise
. So I love to hear from people. If
somebody wants to get in touch, I would be
very welcome. As long as polite kind. No
romance stuff, please. But uh the marriage proposals
get a bit weird uh at the end. But
no, I would love to talk technology and ethics
with um any of your listeners or viewers and I'm
so grateful to you for the chance to have this
chat. No. Thank you so much for coming
on the show. Thank you for your time and
hopefully somewhere in the future we can have another conversation
. I really love this one. So I would
love that too. I will drop you a note
if I am ever in Portugal again, which I
hope I will be all be well and let me
know when it comes out. I'd love to see
it. Yeah. Sure. The marriage proposals get
a bit weird at the end. But no,
I would love to talk technology and ethics with um
, any of your listeners or viewers. And I'm
so grateful to you for the chance to have this
chat. No, thank you so much for coming
on the show. Thank you for your time and
hopefully somewhere in the future we can have another conversation
. I really love this one. So I would
love that too. I will drop you a note
if I am ever in Portugal again, which I
hope I will be all right, be well and
let me know when it comes out. I'd love
to see it. Yeah, sure. Hi guys
. Thank you for watching this interview. Until the
end. If you liked it, please do not
forget to like it, share, comment and subscribe
. And if you like more generally, what I'm
doing, please consider support the show on Patreon or
paypal. You have all of the links in the
description of this interview. The show is brought to
you by En Lights learning and development. Done differently
. Check their website at alights.com. I would also
like to give a huge thank you to my main
patrons and paypal supporters per Larson Jerry Mueller and Frederick
Sunda Bernards, all of election and Weser, Adam
Castle Matthew Whitting Whitting bear. No wolf, Tim
Hollis, Eric, Alania, John Connors, Philip
Forrest, Connelly, Robert Winde Ruin, Nai Zoup
, Mark Nevs Colin Hall, Simon, Columbus,
Phil Cavanagh, Mikel, Stormer, Samuel Andrea Francis
for the Agd Alexander Dan Bauer, Fergal, Ken
Hall, Herzog Michel, Jonathan Libra Jars and the
Correa Eric Heine Marc Smith, Jan We Amal Franz
David Sloan Wilson Yasa, Des Roma Roach Jan Punter
Romani Charlotte. Bliss, Nicole Barbar and Pao Ay
Nele Guy Madison, Gary G Haman, Samo Zal
Arien Y Nick Golden Paul Talent in John Bar was
Julian Price Edward Hall, Eden Brown, Douglas Fry
Franca Beto Lotti Gabriel Pan Cortez, Lalit Scott Zachary
Fish, Tim Duffy, Sonny Smith, John Wiesman
, Martin Aland, Daniel Friedman, William Buckner,
Paul George Arnold Luke Lo A Georges off Chris Williamson
, Peter Lawson, David Williams Di Costa Anton Erickson
Charles Murray, Alex Shaw and Murray Martinez Le Chevalier
bangalore atheists, Larry Daley Junior Holt Eric B.
Starry Michael Bailey. Then Sperber, Robert Grassy Rough
the RP MD I Goran Jeff mcmahon, Jake Zul
Barnabas Radix, Mark Campbell, Richard Bowen Thomas the
Dubner Luke Ni Andre Story, Manuel Oliveira, Kimberly
Johnson and Benjamin Gilbert. A special thanks to my
producers is our web gem Frank Luca Stan, Tom
Weam Bernard Eni Ortiz Dixon Benedict Mueller, Vege Gli
Thomas Trumble Catherine and Patrick Tobin John Carlo Montenegro,
Robert Lewis and Al Nick Ortiz. And to my
executive producers, Matthew Lavender, Serge Adrian and Bogdan
Kut. Thank you for all.